I believe we're again into a future
where people care more about their
digital assets than they do their
physical if you ask most kids what
they'll do if they lost their Fortnight
account they'd be more concerned about
that than their physical clothing
[Music]
artifact is a brand built in the future
we create digital Collectibles which can
be redeemed for physical items we're
sparking the Creator Revolution and
democratizing access to new technology
when I was growing up I loved the
internet and I got into streetwear
fashion and culture from a young age I
was creating pages with millions of
followers and really had a good grasp on
where technology culture and gaming were
going in the future I got into crypto in
2014 I was actually building miners with
my dad and Mining Bitcoin and eth and
then actually sold in 2014 when it
crashed had my first major breakthrough
with a custom sneaker company and then
we were the first to actually do gaming
licensed IP sneakers became friends with
Benoit and Chris the other two
co-founders we had very similar
interests and we set out together to
build this brand of the future
[Music]
2019 we started the company we struggled
to get funding because no one really
understood what we were talking about
about digital items virtual and physical
we went to E3 and everyone was like
virtual Sneakers but for me personally
coming from the sneaker background out
of a successful sneaker company I saw
how sneakers were becoming status
symbols for Gen Z kids and how people
were collecting them and assigning to a
certain tribe and I saw how physical
marketplaces worked with traditional
physical items and I thought that whole
process could be completely more
frictionless with digital assets
[Music]
we got funding and then shortly
afterwards Nike released a patent called
the crypto kicks pattern and that really
scared us from pursuing what we were
doing we carried on and then we fought
for a lot of like covid and tough Market
environments and then now we got
acquired by Nike
we went through with the acquisition
because we believe it was one the first
acquisition in the web 3 space second it
brings what we're doing at a small scale
to a mass audience where people can
understand the technology join our
community and actually grow and learn
with us we're very experimental and
every drop we do we try to innovate and
do something new which is always a risk
but without risk there's no innovation
and so it's a core part of the artifact
brand which is innovation and pushing
the future that we see forward
foreign
I think pre-acquisition we've fundraised
11 million at first it was tricky to
fundraise because people didn't
understand the space or there was no
demand for nfts at the time but then the
nft boom happened and we were in the
right time and the right place to really
take our brand to the next level and
then from there we had unlimited
investing interest and it kind of just
went all uphill from there so it was a
interesting time to see how like pre-nft
boom to post
I'm most proud about our clonex project
it was with my favorite artist Takashi
murakami that project of 20 000
advertisers traded hundreds of millions
of dollars on the secondary Market which
has made a lot of our early investors a
lot of money and we're kind of providing
a lot of value to our community with
airdrops and other utilities that we do
and for me that was a key project in the
artifact Journey that's been amazing
[Music]
we're really targeting our culture and
we come from it we're native to it a lot
of Brands entering the space they don't
understand how internet culture works
we're all Gamers and we come from this
world so we're creating what we think is
the coolest brand and we're here to
democratize access help people engage
with this and also build their own
Brands I would have told my 13 year old
self that you're gonna make a lot of
mistakes and mistakes are a cool part of
learning and to become successful you
can't make the same mistake you made
twice so keep making mistakes be
experimental and eventually if your
vision stays the same you'll end up
where you want to be
foreign